it's a terrific framework on which to
hang a narrative that's always about
curiosity hi I'm Matt Welch
editor-in-chief of recent magazine and
I'm here in Las Vegas with Adam Savage
the co-host of the great show
MythBusters on the discovery channel
which has been going on for seven years
now seven and a half years we've been
filming you tell us about the genesis of
the show how did it come to be created
and and how did it sort of take off like
a half its it remains the most startling
thing that's ever happened to me I was
working as a special effects technician
in san francisco in early 2000s and
Jamie Hyneman who I used to work for and
remain friendly with called me up in the
spring of 2002 and said that he'd gotten
a call from the discovery channel said
they were casting a show called
Mythbusters they wanted a couple of guys
who were interested in building
experiments and testing testing stuff on
a show and would we send in a demo reel
and would be sent in a demo reel the
next day and I said you know this sounds
interesting and I went in with a video
camera and Jamie's assistant shop
assistant shot about two hours worth of
video why as you build and blow up we
actually we discussed a myth we
discussed the lawn chair Larry myth they
said discuss a myth like the balloon
chair guys so we spent 15 minutes
talking about him and then at one point
I I know jamie has a fire cabinet so I
said let's blow something up hey if you
look at the demo reel now it looks
exactly like the show because we're in
the same shop we're in the same space
and we're doing the same stuff and
lighting the lighting this you know a
bunch of fireworks on a metal stand and
then we run away because it's set part
of the shop on fire and discovering went
nuts for it they showed up three weeks
later the production company showed up
three weeks later to start shooting the
pilots we did three episodes in the
summer of two thousand two and we
haven't stopped shooting sense it's now
171 hours of programming Wow yeah now
did you would along sort of career or
personal life of building stuff working
in special
facts but had you been interested up
until that moment in actually trying to
debunk myths and sort of like unbilled
things and no the myth part is a
scarecrow everyone we always say
nobody's ever emailed us thanking us for
the groundbreaking work and urban legend
research we're doing I definitely feel
at this point we have a real insight
into what makes urban legends and great
stories propagate but for the most part
it's a terrific framework on which to
hang a narrative that's always about
curiosity it's always about curiosity
and it turns out that the best way to
satisfy your curiosity happens to be the
scientific method it happens to be see
what you can learn from doing this build
on that they'll build the next thing and
the scientific method happens
fortuitously for us to grid perfectly on
top of a narrative arc and I mean that's
the arc of every episode is we're trying
to figure out how something works by
continually testing it and building our
knowledge on what we've learned before
and we're still thrilled by doing that
in the process of doing that has it sort
of changed your ideas about the
propagation of myths or about society in
the way people has it changed your
politics in any way it hasn't changed my
politics except to make me more
politically active because I realized
that I'm a voice that people that people
pay attention to I am I'm very cognizant
now of the role of the very unexpected
role we play in educating children I
mean we don't pander to kids and we
never set out to make a show that was
educational really I mean that we
understand that that's what it is but if
we attempted to do that we would have
failed there's a veracity to the fact
that we are actually curious about what
we're doing that keeps people watching
and we're now getting emails from people
saying that they're graduating from
college having grown up watching our
show I've been inspired to go into the
sciences because they watch Mythbusters
which is I mean it's humbling and
bizarre and amazing and thrilling what's
the sort of future of this you're just
going to keep doing it until you get
bored or they kick you off the show is
still doing fantastic
we are still leading our demo in our
time slot on discovery on advertising
supported cable after seven years our
viewership stays beautifully beautifully
stable I like to point out that our
ratings died during the presidential
debates but didn't budge during game one
or game seven in the last World Series
oh wow it's very specific viewing
audience I think and the show is still
going strong we want to we'll keep doing
it until they lock the doors and it
doesn't look like there's any end in
sight what are sort of maybe like three
categories if there are three or two or
whatever of types of myths that sort of
obtained in people's consciousness that
you have encountered well we definitely
started out with your kind of laundry
list of urban legends things that you
would have found on the Darwin Awards or
under urban legend sites like snopes com
or the straight dope but we have
branched way out from that realizing
that movie physics movie the way movies
perceive the world and lead you to
believe that every car that goes off a
cliff will blow up into a fireball
that's very fertile territory there's
idioms idiomatic phrases like slipping
on a banana peel finding a needle in the
haystack we're just actually looking at
doing another one where I want to test a
wild goose chase I want to see Jamie
stealing candy from a baby and then
there's a and then there's then there's
the prevailing wisdom about how things
work like the five-second rule which
actually you know is one of those things
when you start to go look at it there
might be something really interesting
there is it as that you drop the
pacifier on the ground if it's only been
there for five seconds we talk about a
three second rule yeah household exactly
it's going down to two in one second we
just did double dipping for instance
that just aired I think this this last
week and we showed that there was no ill
effects from double dipping the amount
of bacteria that you impart back to the
salsa by biting a chip and putting it
back in negligible having worked in
effects and sort of being a participant
in sort of 21st century technologies and
whatnot do you get the sense that people
because they've done their own photo
show
popping and and are on the internet are
they are they given more kind of
skeptical tools now or is it more that
the technology has made it easier to
fabricate things oh that's a good
question I think I mean obviously it's
both I think people are we're always
asked are you guys running out of
material and I mean having just sat down
and gone over 160 stories that will
carry us two seasons ahead at least
we're not running out of stories and we
say we're not going to run out of
stories until people stop believing
stupid [ __ ] and that's never going to
happen people are still just as gullible
and a good store is a good story and you
want to pass it on even if you're not
quite sure it's true I like to imagine
that the web is providing people with
well no actually of course the web is
providing people with more tools to be
skeptical to duck to cross check their
facts not everyone is doing it but
because the web provides so much
information on a first-order retrieve
ability to everybody people can go and
check their facts and they can go I mean
honestly I know that a lot of my
fact-checking has to do with just
reading the style of the writing on
reading on the website I can smell
[ __ ] just by how badly written
something is sometimes it's not
necessarily about you know that the
facts are wrong how many times the use
of course and naturally yes or you need
to keep an open mind because this is the
only interpretation there is for such a
thing yeah well that's great we have
limited the time window on the internet
than YouTube and whatnot so i think
we'll wrap up here for recent TV I'm
Matt Welch